this question is from Pablo is that
putana uh-huh weirdest fan interaction
good or bad when is it good or bad
no weirdest and erection whether it was
a ghost race or that experience I gotta
get my anecdotes ready have you ever
been attacked uh where you like somebody
not not where I was concerned no I had
someone like jump up on stage and take a
cigarette out of my mouth once I'm
generally kind of lost in the moment and
I was like not really aware and so as
long as you know I mean I wasn't yeah I
didn't get pushed over so it's just sort
of the moment came and went you get
where I'm like with the women and stuff
after shows like I'm sure people hit on
you all the time I mean it must be no
and I was gonna say actually the early
days were a little different and yeah
when you were you were kind of asking
like when it when it happened how was
how did it feel in the first tour where
we were in a van and every show was kind
of like oh my god today sold out and
then you drive in the van next place and
oh my god it's sold out yeah that was an
amazing period why that was a really
really special moment and back then you
know you would go out to like a fans
house and to and you know after parties
with you know just your fans and that
that was a lot of fun oh my god then you
get to another kind of like level and
you know you gets weird dudes run a lot
of interference so you don't I don't
know yeah I don't encounter a lot of
girls hitting on me after shows now yeah
I remember opening for Pauly yeah those
were fun because he brought out just a
wild back in the day but my uh I just as
you get older you have to just at the
headline I have to you know I woke up
ahead to the press it just too much
going on now and also don't cheat so
it's like you know I'm have a beautiful
woman home you know but as a young man
when you first when I first did live
shows
yeah how long do you go on the road when
you go on the road well I'll just do a
weekend and like I'm going to since it
at daddy this weekend at yeah two nights
and I come home yeah yeah and then I
don't do City is like you guys do that
must be a [ __ ] hotel livin is a is a
thing yeah two nights would be good
you'd be better what can you guys do
that what can't you just do you know one
weekend you do show to show two cities
that spent two weeks home and then do
another weekend it's you know there's
like economics okay because if you're
gonna have all your team available for
you that's right then they can't take
other work you know so you kind of gotta
like cram it all in as a comic I go by
myself yeah you imagine what they have
to bring everything
yeah right you have a crew got a crew
okay
[Music]